uh hello everybody my name is mario
aquino i'm one of the organizers
for the strange loop conference i'm
joined today
by ambrose bonaire sergeant who is a
past speaker
at strange loop and we're going to be
doing a little bit of catching up
but before i get to ambrose i want to
mention that strange loop is going to be
uh held hopefully this year pandemic
willing
and the dates that we have
the conference scheduled for is going to
be october 1st and 2nd 2021
with a pre-conference day happening the
day before the first
day of the conference on september 30th
the entire conference this year unlike
years past
is going to be held at the st louis
union station hotel
which has actually gotten a lot of
updates uh since the last time we ran
the conference and so it should be
it should have a lot of really fun
things for folks who are coming in from
out of town
to explore and enjoy uh also given
that we've got this global pandemic uh
we'll be working with
local public health officials to make
sure that uh the guidelines
and safety precautions that we take for
the conference will allow everybody to
have
a safe stay while they're in town
visiting us
and hopefully really enjoying themselves
at the conference
if you want to find out more information
you can visit the strangeloop.com
so with all that out of the way uh
ambrose
uh thank you very much for joining me uh
on this
zoom um so as i mentioned
you spoke at strange loop twice already
uh first time in 2014
and he gave a talk on typed closure and
then the second time
um the next year in 2015.
again on type closure and your talk was
uh titled uh from optional to gradual
typing
uh so that was uh six years ago now and
i know a lot has happened since then uh
so i wanted to catch up with you so i i
don't want to
like a lot has happened uh both in type
closure and
for you yeah i you know i wanted to give
you a chance to
to talk about it a little bit yeah
thanks for having me here mario
um but yeah i was you've given me a
little um
you gave me a little homework trying to
um
think about my strange experiences and
i've realized that i i think i pretty
much
since i came to the states in 2014 for
my phd i've
i've been able to attend every year and
it's sort of become a family affair
because i started bringing my wife
uh three or four years ago and
we have our own you know
we still talk about uh strange lip talks
like i was asking my wife like what was
our favorite
strange loops talk and there was one by
um
i forgot her name maybe it's emily but
it was about a voice coding
uh with software about uh called talon
and we actually me and my wife both
ended up using it
and we read it would never have seen it
yeah and i still use it every now and
again
it's you know you just have to learn an
alphabet
and you can just vim with your mouth um
yeah if you check it out on youtube
there's um
uh i think the catch phrase was was
whale quench
which is the uh whale is w quencher's
q so that's how you get out of him well
quench
and yeah it was
yeah it was epic um but yeah
so yeah six years that's nuts
yeah so i guess back then um
i i just started my phd and i remember
starting my first strange loop talk i
had my advisor
in the audience and then my advisor's
advisor next to him with his arms
crossed like leaning back
it was terrifying but like the room was
like
packed it was yeah a very memorable
experience
that was awesome and yeah the next year
um i so that first talk was basically
like what is type closure
and then the next year as i was looking
for research
uh areas and this gradual typing
idea popped up and i ended up doing a
crowdfunding campaign for it
and then this strange loop talk was sort
of a result of that
and um that that's been an interesting
sort of line of work for me to to to
reminisce on because
it it it ended up facing a lot of
implementation issues that effectively
made it
impossible to implement in sort of
it's hard to explain exactly what the
problem was um
this is something that works really well
in racket where you have
um the entire vm
you control everything basically um but
this particular idea doesn't work that
well
in hosted languages and effectively the
idea is this
that if you have an untyped language
and you write a type system for it at
some point there's going to be
communication well how do you make sure
the viola
the variants in variants of the type
system aren't violated
and basically this idea of gradual
typings
proposes a
solution and it turns out because of the
way that
closure is implemented very close to
java
in in the sense it's a light wrapper um
you you end up with these um crippling
problems with final classes because you
need to wrap
things and you can't proxy a final class
anyway
it ended up boiling down to something
like really
annoying and boring like that but
since then rich hickey released spec and
has given me a lot to think about about
what what's the relationship between
generative testing
and static type systems and that is
something that's
that i've been working on over the years
at first when i saw spec
i was i recoiled at this particular
design decision
um if you're familiar with spec you
should check
out what f-specs does when you try and
conform it but basically so let me
let me just say that um so for the folks
who are
who may be watching uh this interview
they may not
uh be familiar either either very
familiar with closure or
very familiar with spec so could you
mention a little bit what
uh what spec is and uh how uh how it
helps
uh describe types in closure yeah well
so closure itself is a lisp that that
runs on the java virtual machine it
compiles to
to java byte code on the flyer and um
closure is an untyped language uh
so the community has been thinking about
ways to verify programs
and there are two main ways at the
moment one is static typing and the
other is runtime verification
and runtime verification you can have
several approaches um
one i don't know perhaps
one of the most innovative approaches
i've seen in this area
was this uh library called closure spec
that rich hickey designed and it's sort
of
uh it takes ideas from all sorts of
things from racket to rdf
and um generative testing you know quick
check
that sort of things and wraps it up in
this coherent package
that um
has left me thinking for a long time
about
why why isn't this normal
uh you know when you say normally why
isn't it
more widely embraced how do you mean i
mean
let's step back from the closure
community for a second um but like
um why haven't i seen something like
this before and
um i ended up asking rich a few
questions about like
why why does that look like a contract
system but it's not a contract system
and sort of um rich had a very specific
design in mind that's it's extremely
pragmatic
and um he rejects this notion of
having to wrap values at runtime because
uh
it's it's quite a performance suck and
effectively if you start wrapping things
in a dynamically typed language
some of the benefits of using the
language are negated because
you know things get checked all the time
and it
it this is an open research area
basically and um
yeah so yeah spec is is a really cool
it's really quite difficult to to define
exactly what spec is
but the basic idea is that you can
summarize what you expect a program to
do
in a specification and spec has
different ways
of utilizing that specification to
destructure data to conform it uh
to check whether a program actually has
uh that specification
and of course if you just want to read
the spec and communicate with other
people
um yeah and
i guess to segue into my own work uh one
thing that spec does not do
is attempt to do any static checking and
um recently i've been playing around
with the spec to see
like well can i add something more
static type-y
something looks like a static type to
spec and
if you think of like if if
any of the viewers are into functional
programming like the identity function
the map function the filter function
if you look at any of the type
signatures of these things in like
haskell or
java or anything like that you'll see
that there's polymorphic
polymorphism it's like for all a b and
this is stuff that
i haven't really seen a good um
answer to verify at runtime so here's
the question
is you have one of these types how can
you verify
using generative testing that it
actually has that type
and i mean i guess
how can you best verify it because it's
impossible to
test for all inputs basically um
but that's sort of the area that my
second strange loop talk has sort of
segued into which is i i have the type
for map
and if i was in the gradual typing sense
of things i would be like well
let's let's wrap map and make sure that
any values that come in
conform to that and any values that come
out conform to this
and then this would i guess it would be
pushed
into production as well it's just like a
whole can of worms effectively but
if you this idea i've been having is
um well let's just step back for a bit
um how could
we simulate
uh checking the static type like as a
black box effectively
so for example uh the identity function
for all x takes an x returns an x
how would we do that how would we if i
just gave you
an object and said is this the identity
function
what would you do and and i said is this
is this of this type and effectively
what i've been working with
um in spec is a way to
enumerate a bunch of useful subtypes of
this type
so but what this identity function
really means is
it says if you give me an integer i will
return an integer
if you give me one i will return one if
you give me nil i'll return nil
if you you know give me any i'll return
any so that's
the basic approach i've been working
with with the generative testing of
functions um yeah so
that that's the stuff that my second
strange loop has sort of evolved into
six years later which is very strange
[Laughter]
i don't know if my advisor would prove
well so you
more recently published a library to
add uh spec support in typed closure
yeah so um can you
can you talk a little bit about that and
is that
is that work effectively um as complete
as
you uh want it to be can you talk about
uh how you have
used it and what sort of feedback you've
gotten from uh folks that are
uh trying to use it uh that are
themselves working with typed closure
yeah so i would say type closure is
definitely
in the in in the in the design
phase at this point uh so for context i
finished my phd last two
july of 2019 and uh i had
basically open problems that explained
why
people have migrated away from type
closure and uh
one of them was the runtime support uh
like something some sort of spec
integration
um but yeah so so that
the the example with the identity
function was
uh was sort of the the flavor of what i
was going for in this
this spec extension um so the idea would
be
that you write a spec or or or a type or
basically something that can be both a
spec and a type i'm i'm not really sure
if
um well i'll put it another way i
i extended closure spec to be able to
write static
types as specs or write specs that look
like static types
so this the type for like identity and
map and
filter and all that stuff you can write
them in spec
and this is basically
a um a big experiment right now i
i don't think anyone should be using it
for anything i'm i'm almost certain no
one is
um but uh the dream is that
you can you can write
uh so this particular the the thing i'm
most excited about
is uh when you're dealing with the uh
the boundaries between types and untyped
code it's often
around these um
little utility functions like an
associate wrapper like
i'll translate that to but basically
functional programming
is about putting building blocks
together
and building towers of
useful helpers and abstractions and
stuff like that and
and you end up with a a bunch of
different
functions and units of program
that um that you need to specify and
then type check
and then if you sort of like recursively
think that through it's like well
quickly you're going to have to specify
everything oh god
we can't do that so um this
stuff with the spec um that this
experimentation i'm doing with spec
is one answer to that question which is
like how far down do you actually do the
static type checking
um you use you effectively need to tell
the type system
what you expect what they should expect
at the other side
of the um the boundary
but the hope is that spec
would would be the thing that you trust
that has actually verified that that
information that specification is
accurate
and yeah you allude to that a little bit
in your 2014 talk
uh which i happened to re-watch recently
in which you advocated for either
adopting
a third party library or adding type
specifications to
your own library because of the sort of
necessity to
give as much information as far as you
can in
uh typed closure code bases
that you may be working in that boundary
that you describe
that is the thing that you want to try
to provide
as much exposure to make that boundary
separating you
uh from in the typed world from as
little as possible
outside of that world to increase the
chances that the
type checker is going to notice things
where types don't line up
based on what your expectations are yeah
i probably said
something like uh i don't have millions
of dollars and i don't have
type scripts behind me i don't have
microsoft behind me well i've certainly
said that as
a sassy remark like that um but that
if you look at the typescript world they
have managed to
to to have these large repositories of
shared type annotations
so the whole community can um
can can share the burden of the i call
this the annotation burden
uh because it's it's truly it's an
immense task
to take an untyped language and then
suddenly have a static type system
that has all these very
precise rules
and you can't fudge anything it has
you have to think every single step um
so yeah and it's a it's a community
effort
that hasn't really panned out in type
closure but
um i i'm not really sure what's going to
happen
with static typing and closure in the
future that there's
there's like i feel like
i started off in maybe 2012 with type
closure
thinking i'm going to make the most
airtight no
compromises type system you know it's
sort of coming from
the the high and mighty uh ivory tower
yeah the ivory tower exactly uh i was
doing my undergrad
uh thesis with uh rowan davies who's
a who has done a similar thing for
standard ml
i believe it or not he took standard ml
and then put a layer of types
over that you know standard ml already
has types
so it was sort of the perfect advisor to
to make you know to keep me up in the
ivory tower
well right on why don't we uh leave it
there
ambrose i want to thank you very much
for making time to
talk with me today uh and uh
i'll just say once again that we are
uh hopefully uh presuming that things
continue to go
in a positive direction with regard to
vaccine distribution
we are hoping to be able to have an
in-person strange loop
conference this year 2021 that again
will be october 1st and 2nd this year
and we hope to see you there ambrose
once again
thanks so much for your time thanks
mario